so there are some new mechanics and dark
souls2 that I feel like you guys need to
know about these are things that aren't
explained in game and whether you're new
to the soul series or not these are
definitely things you want to know
before you're going in we'll start with
the simple mechanics and we'll end with
some of the more complex ones first off
you can now sprint up ladders by holding
down the sprint button tapping the
sprint button while on the ladder will
make you jump off and this is different
to Dark Souls we're tapping made you
slide down so I wonder how many lives
I'll save by telling you this simple
fact the second mechanic we're going to
talk about is the new guard break
critical attack in Dark Souls 2 if you
bash it an enemy's raised shield for
long enough then he'll go into this
guard broken animation tab r1 while he's
in this animation and you'll perform a
critical attack doing massive damage on
the topic of critical attacks parrying
has changed pressing l2 will initiate a
parry animation but you have to time it
really well in Dark Souls 2 tap l2 just
before an enemy attack hits you and if
you time it right then they'll fall flat
on their back which leaves them open for
a critical attack tap r1 while they're
in this fallen state to get the critical
hit animation tap r1 too early while
they're still falling and you'll do
regular damage which causes them to get
up immediately onto the next tip if your
dual wielding weapons you can two-hand
the one in the right hand by tapping
triangle just like in the first game but
if you wanted to hand the weapon in your
left hand then hold down triangle if
you're do wielding two weapons in the
same weapon class for example right here
I'm using two daggers then you'll enter
a dual wielding stance when you hold
down the triangle button if you press l1
and l2 you'll perform special attacks be
warned though sometimes it won't let you
enter this stance even though you have
two of the same weapon and that's
probably because you don't have high
enough stats when I figure out the exact
mechanic behind this I'll put it up on
the screen the fifth mechanic we need to
talk about is that your weapons will now
take durability damage as you progress
through a level you can track this by
looking at the red bar at the bottom of
your weapon to refill this bar and
polish up your weapon just rest a tab on
fire if this weapon reaches the very end
though then you're in trouble you've
broken your weapon and you need to
return it to the blacksmith in order to
get it fixed if you don't fix it then
it's not going to be very effective the
sixth thing we're going to talk about
revolves around this really important
maiden in majula
if you're going to talk to anyone in
majula please talk to her she gives you
your first Estus flask as well as
offering you the ability to level up
with the souls you've acquired don't do
what i did and go through the first few
levels without your Estus flask it's not
fun if you find a Nestor shard in the
world then she can give you another
Estus flask in return next is that you
can burn human effigies in the bonfire
to reduce the chance of invasion by
other players but be careful with
burning these and using these because
Dark Souls 2 becomes really really hard
when you run out of human effigies also
if you find an item called sublime bone
dust in the world then you can burn it
in the majula bonfire to make your estes
more potent more powerful the next tip
revolves around one of my favourite
items which is the pyromancy hand
pyromancy scales with both faith and
intellect so whether you're a sorcerer
or a cleric you can make use of this
item
speaking of caster builds leveling your
attunement stat will not only increase
the amount of spell slots you get it
will also increase the speed at which
you cast and while we're on the topic of
stats adaptability is a new stat that
increases your animation speeds this
includes things like chugging and Estus
flasks or crushing a life gem or raising
your shield adaptability also increases
your resistance to volatile elements in
the world like poison or cursing you
can't really go wrong with adaptability
as just leveling it up means that you
become better suited to every situation
now this next thing isn't particularly a
new mechanic but it's definitely more
common in Dark Souls 2 so I found that
when you talk to almost every NPC
exhausting their dialogue will get you
more than just story and you'll find
that if you talk to more in pcs they
will appreciate it in some way maybe
they'll give you an item or maybe
they'll move to a better location just
make sure you talk to people for example
I'm going to use this to segue into the
blacksmith who gives you a hammer if you
to it oh and also in Dark Souls 1 you
didn't have to level up your catalyst or
the spell casting weapon you used for it
to be powerful but in Dark Souls 2 make
sure you level up your catalyst with
Titan ID at the blacksmith the same goes
for your shield as these two things
become way more powerful if you level
them up do not forget to do this on a
final note I'm going to tell you the
mechanic for my new favorite thing in
the game which is torches I love the way
they look the lighting in this game is
incredible toggle your options while
standing at a bonfire to light one of
the torches you have in your inventory
each torch contributes 5 minutes of lit
time to the counter now while torches
look incredible make sure you use your
time with them carefully because they
can burn out and they can eventually
leave you in the dark and I reckon that
pretty much covers it guys I can't think
of much else if there's anything you
think I missed just write it down in the
comments I just wanted to make this
video so that you'd be equipped to
tackle Dark Souls 2 you know these
things would have taken a while to
figure out on your own so hopefully it's
a bit of a shortcut for new players
remember to Kindle the bonfire if you
liked this video and have fun dying I'll
catch you guys in the next video and I
hope you're enjoying all the content
surrounding the release of this game
there's so much content to make but so
little time anyway talk to you again
soon later Dark Souls where do I start
for the better part of a year a huge
part of my life has revolved around this
game if I could sum up how I feel about
it in one video then I wouldn't have 70
other videos dedicated to it